[Music]
if you go into a diner now are you going
through diner fifty years ago a feeling
is the same it's the experience that
keeps these places going right it's what
keeps everybody in here coming back to
this diner we had this really cool idea
we had a way to really differentiate our
stations experience using an app using
technology getting that experience right
and simple is so important for us oh
thank you
as consumers expectations are changing
because of technology in digital we said
why should the fueling experience be any
different we knew what we wanted from a
consumer experience but what we didn't
know was exactly how to do it right so
when we could focus more on the consumer
experience and IBM was then driving a
technical solution I felt like IBM was
as committed to our objective as we were
so after all this hard work that we put
into this mobile app what did we get in
a bit at the end of the day we have a
platform that our consumers life and
they give us their loyalty you know the
threats are always changing and we can
trust in the IBM cloud that when we put
something out there and consumers are
trusting us with their data that it is
protected and it is secure you guys
scale with us we don't have to worry
about it so our servers and
infrastructure and all that stuff that
just works the highlight moment for me
is just that that roll from disbelief to
impressed and when you watch somebody's
face go oh wow it worked it's super cool
next time you stop for gas let's do that
yeah just you'll see what I'm talking
about
so here we go pay for fuel good to see
that I'm gonna earn five points a gallon
here
I'll hit pump 16 I got my credit card
there it knows I don't want my receipt I
want it to be emailed to me then I'll
just hit authorized pump all right grab
the nozzle pick our gray didn't touch
anything else we're gonna get our points
pumps on fuel okay so we're two nuts
you